well joining me now from the extreme
hangout at the climate Summit is the
model actor and Ambassador for the
project Lily Cole so Lily Cole lovely to
have you on the show thanks so much for
joining us so explain to us why you feel
that transparency and traceability is
such an important issue for the fashion
industry
I think it's an important issue for
every industry
um we're looking at Fashion but we're
also looking at critical raw materials
agroforestry and the idea is that these
learnings could be applied to every
single industry it's important because
if we don't know what's going on we
can't make choices we can't make choices
as consumers there's a rising tide of
green washing happening because of the
lack of information that's available but
also companies can't necessarily make
the changes they need to make happen if
they don't understand their own Supply
chains which is often the case and also
governments won't be able to know
whether they are actually meeting the
targets they're setting because they
don't have the data and the information
to understand the impacts of the
businesses operating in their countries
and there has been way too much opacity
for too long it's not a technical
problem it's arguably a problem of Will
and political and corporate will to
bring the level of transparency that
needs to happen to supply chains that's
so interesting that you say that I mean
the fashion industry does have very
complex Supply chains you're saying that
there are some producers who aren't even
aware of what's Happening further down
the chain is that what you're saying
yeah
yeah I've consulted for fashion
companies that want to improve their
their impact and they genuinely can't
get the data to go back to the beginning
of the supply chain when they try to
they can often see the first layer or
two so the factories that are maybe
manufacturing the clothes but if you ask
them where does the cotton actually come
from who are the farmers what are the
impact on the ground at the very
beginning of your supply chain they
often don't have access to that
information and if you imagine we live
in a world where it's been shown that
Google can can Google's algorithms can
understand that a woman's pregnant
before she even knows she's pregnant
that's how well data can understand
customers I don't think it's a technical
problem it's a it's a it's a problem of
where we focus our energy and we could
get this level of data and information
so that customers can make better
choices companies can make better
choices and ultimately governments can
do the job and and regulate and track
the goals that are being set
and we know that there are lots of
challenges in making sure that the
industry is has less of a carbon
footprint but is it particularly bad as
well because of the frenetic Pace at
which it moves the fact that the fashion
drives change constantly
yeah I think that's a very good question
and that's the other thing I've been
trying to talk about this week is not
just transparency it's also the rate of
production consumption and growth GDP is
this kind of religion by which most
companies if not all companies are being
led by as a primary metric and they need
to rethink other kpis to also think
about circularity the dress I'm wearing
I bought second hand you know how do we
expand and extend the lifespan of the
the products we already have in
circulation if you look at the level of
recycling in Fabrics the level of
recycling and electronics it's
shockingly low and we really really need
to reform that very quickly to reduce
the amount of extraction we're doing and
the amount of farming we're doing in the
natural world
um so yeah questioning business models
questioning the central position of GDP
growth is the key metric and looking at
circularity feel essential to go
anywhere near the targets we're setting
and on that point I would just say you
know the UN has called for all
Industries to halve emissions 40 five
percent reduction by 2030 to say within
safe planetary boundaries many fashion
companies have made the commitment to
halve their emissions by 2030 but if you
look at the data year on year emissions
are still going up around the world and
so there's this huge gap between the
pledges that are being made the promises
that are being made and the actual data
of what's happening and the reality is
we can't greenwash physics like physics
is not going to be greenwashed you know
so we have to be really truthful and
really realistic with ourselves as
individuals as communities as companies
as countries as an International
Community to get very realistic about
making sure the pledges we're making are
being put into practice and taking the
probably quite radical actions that need
to happen in order to put those
Pleasures into practice okay Lily Cole
very interesting to talk to us to talk
to you rather thanks very much indeed
for joining us there from charmel Sheikh
thank
you